because I keep Sabbath I I don't use
Kindle because when I'm reading a book
and I hit Sabbath I have to turn off the
Kindle so that means that I have tons
and tons and tons of physical books when
you move from Los Angeles to Florida I
had about 7 000 volumes I had to discard
probably 4 000 of them
um and then I've built that back up now
so I'm probably gonna have to go through
another round where I put them somewhere
else I tend to tab books rather than
highlighting them because I can't
highlight on Sabbath so I have like the
little stickers and I put them in the
book so a typical book from me you can
see it on the book club will be like
filled with tabs on the side things that
I want to take not actually uh I got a
person who I I
um pay to go through and write down in
files the quotes that I've that I like
from the book so I have those handy
um so which is a good way for me to
remember what it is that I've that I've
read
because I I read probably
some routine three and five books a week
and then the uh in a good week five uh
and then I you know write I read and
then I go pick up my kids from school at
3 30. so according to my kids I have no
job uh there I'm there in the mornings
until they leave for school I pick them
up from school I hang out with them
until they go to bed which is usually 7
30 or so so I'm helping them with their
homework and I'm playing with them and
I'm taking them on rides in in the brand
new Tesla which my son is obsessed with
uh and uh and then I put them to bed and
then I sit back down I prep for the next
day go through all those media sources I
was talking about compile kind of a
schedule for what I want the show to
look like and and run a show it's very
detail-oriented nobody writes anything
for me I write all my own stuff
um so every word that comes out of my
mouth is my fault